great question from at gong show west is
bill belichick
rooting for or against
tom brady this weekend our floor
against bruce arians i would assume he's
going to be rooting against bruce arians
hoping that tom brady can't win one
without him because it certainly makes
bill belichick look better to say hey we
were a good pairing and it only worked
when we were together not when he's with
bruce arians it was about the coach and
the quarterback not just the quarterback
mike
yeah we're not eventually going to have
a ton of data points we can look to in
this broader question of
how will tom brady fare without bill
belichick and vice versa
will only have as many seasons as brady
plays and based upon his own timeline
he's got two more well he's one for one
in getting to the conference
championship round and belichick is
all for one in getting to the playoffs
so the sooner you pull the plug on brady
the less glaring it looks so look i
i patriots fans tom curran told me
earlier this week that some
are aligned with brady and want him to
win it's no threat to the patriots
others are aligned with belichick and i
think if you are
a patriots fan at some level you don't
want anything to undermine
your accomplishments tom brady going
elsewhere and winning you could argue in
a weird sort of way undermines what he
did with the patriots
oh no question mike we had that whole
debate when they moved
on from tom brady was it the coach or
was it the quarterback
and i'm still of the mind that it was
both even if tom brady wins another one
this year i still think it was the both
that made that dynasty i don't see a
buck's
dynasty coming uh with this again like
you said
over the next two years even if they win
it this year they're not gonna win two
more i wouldn't think
to have three in a row which again would
make tom brady
the goat which he already is i guess
and here's the key and i can say this
with absolute certainty because there is
no way i can be proven wrong
which is the best way to express
abstinence certainty
if tom brady was still on the patriots
there's no way in hell
they'd be playing this weekend against
the bills or the chiefs no way
no how they they may not have even made
the playoffs if brady had stayed with
the patriots
and it's a great point mike because i
completely agree with you i think i
don't think the patriots
would be where the buccaneers are this
year it took him going to a really good
team to make this happen and it's worked
it's worked for tom brady it's work for
the bucks it didn't work so well for the
patriots
who you got this weekend i got the
chiefs and the buccaneers
i'm going with the two home teams again
mike stick with those home teams
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports